alright let's talk about Psychopaths I
think a fitting way to end this show
with these two Psychopaths and I'm
sitting next to but first let's look at
the definition of psychopaths
psychopathy is a personality disorder
characterized by shallow emotions in
particular reduced fear stress tolerance
lacking empathy called heartedness
lacking guilt egocentricity superficial
character manipulative nasir
responsibility impulsivity and
antisocial behaviors such as parasitic
lifestyle and criminality now I bring
this up not because I just want to talk
about psychos but because Time magazine
had an interesting article on the type
of professions that kind of breed
Psychopaths versus the ones that don't
so let's take a look at that
okay and now here's where we're all
gonna be in trouble the ones that breed
Psychopaths a number one CEO I think
we're all gonna have fun with that we're
just gonna read a couple of them to
lawyer three media TV radio let's put
slash Internet there and then we're all
in trouble
salesperson surgeon journalist now you
can see most of these things with the
exception of police over these are
pretty well-paying jobs
general orgy person that's the
interesting one the whole battle I
missed that one now look at the ones
that do not breed Psychopaths II and
this is really fascinating so care aid
nurse therapist crass person charity
worker teacher creative artist doctor
accountant okay is absolutely that is a
flip over yeah
I mean it we could also do this like we
could to have like a little like a head
of like let's say Bill O'Reilly yeah and
you could just like like magnet you just
go well he's a CEO boom I think he's a
lawyer boom media TV radio now that one
doesn't fit he's a sales person boom I
think he played a surgeon once on TV
boom calls himself a journalist that's -
I mean you know literally look at all
the people we know that fit one through
three seven and so this up for me
because I don't want to feel that we're
Psychopaths
we're all number three well it's you
know it's there's a lot of gray area you
know the other thing too they had in
this article was the list of traits you
know and how you could kind of you know
say the name of these traits differently
and I thought charismatic was one and
then superficial charm
of the nice you know the kind of meaner
way of saying it person who can make
hard decisions could also be seen as the
person who has emotional poverty you
know so there there is a continuum here
and and I think during the day we we
swing between not psychopath and not you
know blob of amoeba which I think is the
two extremes here we cycle between these
two things because we have some distance
sometimes we have to make the hard
decision and sometimes we have to be the
one with the shoulder that you cry on
and and I think for many of us in this
business in particular we feel torn
because if you're in showbiz we know
it's cutthroat it is a psychopathic
industry it doesn't believe in caring
about your family your mental health
your physical health just as a worker in
it it will keep coming expectations'
everything because we are creative
artists and we're looking for an outlet
so you know but the thing is when you
look at these CEOs and see the decisions
they need to make and see how some of
them run their companies and hedge fund
guys to hedge fund guys even scarier
that really when I first learned about
this like a couple years ago I learned
about this really just chilled me to the
bone to think wow we are like all of our
greatest MBA programs are training
people to be more psychopathic and less
it here for Humanity no wonder we're in
the [ __ ] shape right now to that point
then isn't aren't these people the hedge
fund guys and the guys on Wall Street
that are doing all these you know I
don't even know what the words the
annuities and all the trickery all the
financial trickery and the derivative
that they're doing it at a computer so
they're not even seeing the human and of
it so does so does even we've talked a
lot about technologies today but that
even that it's now creeped into they
don't have to see the people that
they're [ __ ] over basically I just
remember that from American Psycho I
have to go return some videotapes yeah
everyone thought that guy was a pretty
upstanding ya know it's look it all it's
all connected as my mother would love to
say it's all connected
it's again a lack of
analog you know you don't have funding
you you don't identify people early
enough because you're not really
interfacing with them there's not enough
social work being done in the in the
primary school system to identify people
that need help and that need a little
special extra attention ie watching very
closely there then they're then pushed
through the system they have they have
all of the things on your list that they
haven't mastered and yet they learned
how to kind of mask them for it and then
you start getting rewarded yeah
Puritan work ethic you know hard work
pull yourself up by your bootstraps
you're going to be rewarded in the
afterlife that was the original concept
of that you're going to be rewarded in
the afterlife so do what you have to do
in this you know in this area is you're
going to be rewarded if you're
successful in the end
ah and you know I'm more of a reward
you'll get it here kind of guy I hope
that's what I always hope the black and
white nature of how you know there's
like two columns and there was the left
column on the right column you know
could you start having discussions like
you know General George Patton
Psychopaths
you know like start to think about it in
the gray of that certain of certain
traits certain ability to be emotionally
dead inside or cut off from every
emotion makes you effective at certain
jobs and in certain situations when
you're you know fighting World War two
you can't have everybody out there going
so how do you feel about this minefield
think about it in not that we need to
breed Psychopaths but we can't just
think about like good or bad and that
they're all Patrick Bateman which looks
good on and then it's situational I mean
you know a therapist if you're dealing
with a client who's suicidal you're not
gonna be like oh let me give you a hug
you're like I'm sorry I'm putting you in
for a 48 hold because you're gonna hurt
yourself
yeah you know you have to be the the
dictator in that moment and you have to
be you know the cold and have some
emotional poverty you can't be aching
with your depressed patient you know so
it's very situational that's interesting
the idea that so for the for the money
guys they need the distance and can just
look at the computer so they can screw
the people they don't know but for the
the soldiers and the military commanders
they need
the reverse in a weird way does that
what does what does our me because
they'd camp identity look you know look
at some of the protein film but look at
Full Metal Jacket
you know look at what that process of
that film was part of that journey was
taking this funny guy who they called
the Joker
Matthew Modine and just dehumanizing to
the point where in that fateful scene he
can draw down on that female sniper and
blow her away yeah you know that's the
journey to psyche it's like a psychopath
II yeah you know it's interesting all
right so let's bring it home and talk
about money because there obviously is
some connection between all this and
money if you looked at the left-hand
column a lot of money there right here
come the nurses not making that much
money the the therapist things like that
so how much of this is inherently
related to the quest for money again it
all of it I think I mean that I said the
culture you know the culture supports
more psychopathic you are and but you're
not killing and actually murdering
people the more likely you're gonna do
well in business I mean that's the way
the business model is set up there's not
a lot of humanity in in any I mean it's
funny because you know you look at
lawyers I mean there's a lot of great
lawyers who work for free and they're
there because they're trying to do good
and they're trying to bring actual
justice you know there's a lot of you a
lot of all these people on the left that
left call and that do do it for the
right reasons but yeah this culture is
set I mean we watch football every
weekend look you know think about it
this way you know corporate let's go
citizens united if corporations are
people maybe we just have to have those
corporations deemed Psychopaths